Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to One Late Night: Deadline!
So - I'm an employee....
Late at night, trying to get something done for some project.
*bleep*
Okay... oh hello! Who the hell are you? Oh what the hell? Is that me? (wilford is your father Mark)
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) Wilford's moves like jagger
Okay, then.
*bleep*
Why am I here late at night? Why? WHYYYY?
Why the music kick up?
*elevator ominously opens*
Hello?
I didn't call that elevator.
What are you doing? (I highly doubt that a ghost is THAT small Mark.)
*bleep* This is my desk...
[reading off of screen] "Wtf? last night I was..." What the fuck is that attachment?
Ugh!
That irks my creepo factor. That's the first decent thing I've seen. (creepo factor over 9000!)
Heh. (ew.)
Ohhhh! I'm so slooooooow!!!
OH!!!!
I'm so slow!
*bleep* Oh, I want to like this game
I don't want to say bad things about it right away,
But God damn!
Here the vase skip to my lou skip to my lou Da dippity-doo (random references and scatting)
Where's the coffee?
Where's the coffee?!
WHERE'S THE COFFEE?!!
AHHHH!
AHHHHH!!
Im'ma lose my mind! Where is the coffee?! (I do not know!)
AHHHHHH!! WHERE'S THE COFFEE?!?!! (Mark's biggest rage)
AHHHHHHH!
AHHHHH!!
AHH! (fnaf reference much?), this is what happens when I don't have my coffee, I just get a little aggravated. *irritated, actually* Coffee!
Coffee!
Coffee! (oh no it is the invastion of zombiplier)
Heh.
*wild Markimoo sounds*
*rapid slurping from the wild markimoo in it's horrifying habitat*
Okay.